in October in Malang East Java this is
how one of the world's worst Stadium
disasters unfolded some fans had entered
the pitch after the match ended police
then fired tear gas at fans including
those in the stands people tried to flee
but many of the exits were shut causing
overcrowding at the gates 135 people
were killed in the resulting Crush many
of them children and nearly 600 people
were injured
this month five men who were on trial
for their involvement in the incident
learned their fate the head of the
organizing committee for the match heard
his sentence first of 18 months in
prison
I declare the defendant Abdul Harris has
legally and convincingly been found
guilty of committing a crime because of
his negligence causing people to die
and shortly after another match official
a security officer was sentenced to one
year in prison
the prosecution said the men were
responsible for the safety of the match
including stopping overcrowding and
ensuring Gates were open but the match
officials say police should shoulder
most of the blame for firing tear gas in
the stadium
the defendant Abdul Harris sent the
situation spiraled when police used tear
gas
the stadium doors have been like that
since a long time ago even if there was
tear gas even if the gate was open there
would still be a problem
three police officers will be sentenced
next week with the prosecution
requesting sentences of three years in
prison
some relatives if the victims told Al
Jazeera they are in disbelief at
sentences they consider to be too
lenient
as a parent of a victim I am very
disappointed the families did not expect
this I respect the law but this is not
final we must appeal
weono says he will never stop Seeking
Justice against those he holds
responsible for the death of his
daughter Jessica Washington altazira
Jakarta